it might look like a river but this is
actually a paddy field
in the village of sampang in patti
regency this community of farmers in
central java
is trying to salvage their crops days of
severe flooding have destroyed most of
their hard work
and most of the rice is rotten
[Music]
look all around everything is ruined
there is no harvest
this community is used to heavy rains
but farmers told al jazeera past floods
didn't reach the paddy fields
they say land degradation is to blame
for the worsening flooding
there are many mining activities going
on uphill mining for the cement
factories forest destruction for
plantations
when it rains the water flows straight
to the juana river and it overflows
the disaster agency says seven thousand
hectares of land is flooded
and in some areas the water rose more
than a meter and a half
aside from the la nina factor we cannot
deny this flood is caused by
environmental destruction
especially in the forest environmental
groups are campaigning for a moratorium
on mining permits
they blame the worsening floods on
upstream mining for the cement factory
but local authorities in parti maintain
the floods are caused by heavy rain
these floods are because the jonah river
overflowed it happens annually when the
rainfall is high
this week severe flooding affected
thousands of households in jakarta
and nearby cities and local authorities
also blamed heavy rain
flooding in java causes millions of
dollars of damage
every year in jakarta and in smaller
cities
and authorities are often reluctant to
make the connection
between environmental damage and the
worsening floods
in patti the local government says it
will give seeds to the affected farmers
but the farmers are still concerned
if it continues like this all is lost we
can't plant again now
seeds they say will not be enough if the
bigger issues aren't addressed as well
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta